as a teenager I was fascinated with the
boring world I wanted to be like
Hermione Granger I wanted to be a
powerful witch with a
wand out of all the Spells I really
liked AO I could say AO and name
anything and it would fly into my hands
even if it's a restricted book locked
and hidden inside the headmaster's
office but as you might have noticed I
did not get into
Hogwarts so I came to my backup school
and and I made my own
magic I can now I can have a spells now
that are even more powerful than Hermes
because I don't need a wand
I can see the
invisible let me show you my first spell
for example I want to find my black
shirt in my closet that I lost I put on
my AR headset and I say
a within a matter of seconds my shirt
would light
up like I said I can see the invisible
[Applause]
so how does this spell work how did I
made an AR headset able to see what my
own eyes cannot
see my trick is to use wireless signals
like Bluetooth and
Wi-Fi these signals are great this is
exactly why you can get Wi-Fi from
another room
so these signals are sent by this
headset they are scattered in the
environment they go through boxes and
then are um reflected back from all of
these hidden objects including my
shirt with then design algorithms that
uses these reflected signals to find
these objects let me show you how these
algorithms
work first the headset tries to
understand its environment by creating a
virtual 3D
map and then as I walk in the
environment it keeps sending these
Wireless signals tries to collect all of
the reflections and then combines them
to collect in collects this information
and then tries to locate the object that
I was looking for then after sometimes
it becomes confident about it and then
tells me here it is this is the glob
which is where the object I want is and
I can go and grab
it bes IDE helping me having these
magical powers it has a lot of
industrial applications for example in a
warehouse it can help warehouse worker
to find packages and then it can guide
them through the warehouse to find these
packages in a retailer store it can help
the store associates to pack customer
order and find misplace
items it also has a lot of other
application in logistics and
Manufacturing so having an x-ray vision
is very cool it's better than what her
mind had but sometimes I'm just so lazy
I don't want to go ahead put my headset
on and then say AO and then go and find
my key grab it under the pile so I was
thinking what if I had a robot that knew
my spell so I taught my spells to a
robot
my robot can find my keys and bring them
to me let me show it to you for example
here my keychain is hidden under the
pile in the
basket my robot is able to search the
environment and locate my keys with
centimeter level accuracy purposefully
declutter the environment and then grab
the keys and bring them to
me so how do we do
this we built an specialized gripper
instead of a
wand so it has a camera and a wireless
sensor which sends the similar signals
like the headset that I just talked
about so this is great now the scrier
can locate the
keys but there's one challenge what if I
put my robot in a completely new
environment for example put it in the
living room and ask it to find a remote
control how does this robot adapt itself
to completely new environment and a
completely new object if the robot does
exactly the same steps as before then it
can only find a key in a
basket we designed AI algorithm
specifically to help this robot to adapt
itself to completely new environment and
find object it has never seen before
for example here is trying to find a
remote control on a couch in a living
room it has never seen before it's able
to find it and then bring it to me and I
can go and grab this remote control and
then watch my favorite
show magical x-ray vision can change the
way we think about our environment and
the way we interact with our environment
it opens up new possibilities that we
never thought they are
possible for example it can help our
future robots in our homes to help us it
can also help us interact with our
future Smart Homes in ways we never
imagined
before but the application that I'm
personally very excited about is helping
our First Responders to find and track
humans in conditions with low
visibility or helping humans under the
rubble after disaster
hits and as the cherry on top it can
help those of us who did not get into
Hogwarts to get one a step closer to the
barding world thank
you